[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAL OSHRI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Gal
Oshri, and I'm here
to talk to you about
TensorBoard and what's
new in TensorFlow's
visualization toolkit.
So how many you have
used TensorBoard before?
Awesome.
So as you know,
TensorBoard helps
you visualize a lot of the data
that comes out of TensorFlow.
It has a wide
variety of features,
but today we're going
to talk about a couple
of new additions.
So I'm actually going to
switch over to a demo.
So this is Colab, a service
from Google Research that
makes it really easy to get
started with TensorFlow.
If you've seen the
TensorFlow documentation,
you've probably used Colab.
A few minutes before
the demo, I made sure
that we have installed
TensorFlow 2.0
Alpha and a couple
of other setup steps,
so we don't have to
do them right now.
We're going to use
the FashionMNIST data
set, one that I'm sure
you've never seen before.
And we're going to train a
really simple keras sequential
model, one that just has
a few layers, including
dents and dropout layers.
We're going to train
it with a fit API
and give it the TensorBoard
callback so that we
make sure that we log the
right data to visualize
in TensorBoard.
Now, if you've
used Colab before,
you'll know that
at this stage, we
would need to download the
logs to our local machine,
make sure TensorBoard is set
up, point it at those logs,
and then look at them, and
then go back to Colab again.
That's not very convenient.
So what we've done is enabled
showing TensorBoard directly
within Colab.
You'll notice that the way
that we start TensorBoard here
is exactly the same as
in the command line.
It's the same command, just
has the magic function in front
of it.
The same thing will also
work in Jupyter Notebooks.
So let's see what's different.
Well, first of all, when
using the keras callback,
we now have train validation
showing up on the same charts
to make it much easier to
compare them in accuracy, loss,
and other metrics.
This makes it easier to detect
things like over-fitting.
In the graphs
dashboard, while seeing
all of the ops and
auxiliary information
is useful for many
scenarios, sometimes you just
want to see what is the model
that I created in keras.
What are the layers in it?
So you can now switch
to the keras tag
and just view that model.
We can expand this to see the
actual layers that we added.
There's several other
APIs for using TensorBoard
within Notebooks that let you
change the height of the cell
as well as list the
active instances
within your Colab notebook.
But we're not going
to look at that today
because I want to switch gears
and talk about hyperparameter
tuning.
Now the model that we
created was extremely simple,
and we've paid a couple of
hyperparameters for it--
the dropout rate, the number
of units in the dense layer,
and the optimizer.
Now, if we really cared about
that model's performance,
we're going to want to
try out different values.
We're going to want to
experiment several of them
and see which one leads
to the best model.
The way this would look
today in TensorBoard
is that you might include
all of that information
about what the values
are into the run names,
so as you can see here
in the bottom left.
You can then filter
using regular expressions
or go to the chart
and try and hover over
which line had the
best result to identify
which values were good.
It's not the best
experience, so let's see
if we can do something better.
Now, what I'm going
to show next is
something that's
going to change,
both in terms of
the APIs and the UI.
But it is available
in the TF 2.0 Alpha
today, so you can try it out.
We're going to do several
additional imports
and define which values of the
hyperparameters we want to try.
We'll start out with just a
few so that we don't take up
too much time during the demo.
We're going to log a summary
that tells TensorBoard what
were the hyperparameters
that we care about
and what were the metrics.
We then wrap the
existing training code
that we had, just
to make sure that we
log the accuracy at the
end on the validation set
and also tell TensorBoard
that the experiment
has started and finished.
This time, we're going
to start TensorBoard
before doing our training
because, in most cases,
your training will take
longer than one minute
and you want to view the
TensorBoard while your model is
training to understand
its progress.
So we've started it.
It has no data.
But once a couple of epochs
of training have finished,
we can refresh it and
start to see something.
Now you'll notice
in the top, we now
have the HPARAMS
dashboard, which shows us,
at first, a table where each
run is represented by a row,
and we have columns for
each of the hyperparameters
and metrics.
As the runs finish, the
table will become populated
with them.
On the left, we have the
ability to filter and sort.
So we can say that
we don't actually
care about the number
of units or we only
want to see experiments where
the accuracy is at least 85.
So before we proceed
further, I want
to actually cheat a little
bit and log and access
some completed
experiments where we've
run a wider range of
combinations of values
for the hyperparameters.
Now while this is
loading, I want
to point out that I'm
pointing TensorBoard directly
at a folder in my Google Drive.
So I had all my
TensorBoard logs maybe
on another machine, uploaded
them to my Google Drive,
and then I can
access them directly
within my Colab Notebook.
So this takes a moment
to load, but hopefully
when I refresh we now see it.
And I can switch over
to the HPARAMS dashboard
and now see a more complete
set of experiments.
I can switch over to
the Parallel Coordinates
View, which shows
me a visualization
where we have an axis for each
hyperparameter and each metric.
Each run is represented
by a line that
passes through all
these axes at the points
corresponding to its
hyperparameters and values.
I can click and drag on any axis
to select a particular range.
So in this case, I've
selected the experiments
with a relatively high accuracy,
and they become highlighted
in this visualization.
I can immediately see
that all these experiments
used the Adam Optimizer
as opposed to SGD
and had a relatively high number
of units in the dense layer.
This gives me some
great ideas about what
I can experiment with next.
I can also view the
scatterplot view,
which shows me the correlations
between the different
hyperparameters and metrics.
I can, again,
select a region here
to view those points
across the other charts.
So just to summarize,
we've looked at TensorBoard
in Colab, an easier
way to compare
the train validation
runs, visualizing
the keras conceptual graph,
and better hyperparameter
tuning with the
HPARAMS dashboard.
All of this information is
available as documentation
in TensorFlow.org/TensorBoard.
We also have a
demonstration upstairs,
and we'd love to hear from you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]